- Hi, I'm Meagan from Khan Academy.
And in this video,
we're gonna explore Khan
Academy's course mastery system.
At Khan Academy we're
devoted to mastery learning,
and build our content around
our course mastery system.
However, a question we hear
frequently from teachers is,
what exactly do we mean by
course mastery on Khan Academy?
Course mastery on Khan Academy,
is a feature that allows teachers
to set and track long term
learning goals for students,
while encouraging students
to work at their own pace.
Currently course mastery is available
for courses with full practice content.
All of our math courses
including AP Calculus,
AB, BC, AP Statistics
and our Get Ready for grade level courses,
as well as Grammar, High
School Biology, AP Biology,
AP Physics 1, US government and civics,
AP US government and politics,
US History, AP US history,
World History Project
Origins, AP macroeconomics,
Microeconomics, AP Microeconomics,
and AP Computer Science Principles.
Assigning course mastery goals,
allows teachers to set
and track long term goals.
Let's walk through
how to assign course mastery
goals to your students.
When you log in to Khan Academy,
you'll land on the teacher dashboard.
Click on the name of the class,
you want to assign a mastery goal.
On the left hand side navigation,
go to the course mastery placement tab,
if you haven't done so already,
at the on grade level
course you currently teach.
And if you're a math teacher,
add to get ready for grade level course.
If you're about to start the school year,
we recommend assigning the get
ready for grade level course,
as a course mastery goal,
to have students begin the year,
by gap filling and
strengthening fundamentals,
before diving into on grade level skills.
For example, if I were
a 5th grade teacher,
I would start the year
by signing the get ready
for fifth grade course.
Click the blue button, add these courses.
Now you'll be on the course
mastery placement page.
Click assign goal,
you can confirm your assign
the desired goals to students,
by selecting course mastery placement
on the left-hand panel,
and you will now see the
current mastery goals,
assigned to students in your class.
A students work on Khan Academy.
You can also add additional courses,
for students to work on, either
below or above grade level.
You can assign the same course
for all students to master,
or you can assign different courses
to individuals or groups of students.
We recommend using Khan
Academy's skill report,
to look more closely at students progress,
and determine the best goal,
or goals for each student.
Now let's look a little closer
at what students see in terms
of course mastery goals.
When students log in to Khan Academy,
they will view on their learner home page,
each student will be able
to see their teacher,
or class name on the left hand side.
By clicking on the class,
students will see their mastery goal.
A student can click the goal at any time,
and continue from where they left off,
to make progress towards their goal.
Students can continue working
toward their mastery goal,
on the iOS and Android apps as well.
Every skill or concept has
multiple mastery levels,
and students earn additional
points, with each new level.
There are several ways
for students to practice,
they can practice a single
concept at a time on an exercise,
or they can practice a
mix of different concepts,
on a quiz, unit test, course
challenge or mastery challenge.
As students get questions right,
they move up from not started,
to familiar, to proficient,
the top level is mastered.
Students can only get to mastered,
by getting to proficient,
and then getting that concept
right, on a unit test,
course challenge, or mastery challenge.
Most teachers recommend,
having students start
with the course challenge,
or specific unit tests within the course.
This way both students and teachers,
can quickly identify gaps
and strengths in student knowledge,
in order to provide the right content,
and right support in the right moment.
When students are stuck
or missed questions,
their mastery level moves down,
and a symbol appears next to the concept,
to help them remember where to focus.
If students are consistently
missing problems
about a concept, they'll
move to attempted status,
and a red dot will appear
next to that concept.
Mastery of individual concepts,
contributes to unit progress,
and to overall course progress.
A mastery goal is considered achieved,
once a student reaches 90% mastery,
though they can still access
previous goals, at any time.
Students can always see
what they've completed,
and what they should work on next.
Additionally, once students
have begun working in a course,
they will receive mastery challenges,
which appear at the
top of the course page.
Mastery challenges,
highlight opportunities
for students to engage
in personalized spaced
repetition of the skills,
students have already started practicing.
Research shows that
spiraling skills over time,
and across lessons,
is a key component to minimizing
student learning loss,
and improving knowledge retention.
We'll be diving deeper into
reports, in a later lesson.
But let's take a quick look,
at where to find mastery
progress, for students.
Starting at the teacher
dashboard, select a class,
select course mastery progress,
from the left-hand panel.
This report shows student
progress on the selected course.
First you'll see class progress,
towards overall course mastery,
and the median mastery
for the class as a whole.
Below, you'll see the
mastery for each unit,
perhaps it's the start of the year,
and you're focusing on this first unit.
By clicking on any unit,
you can see the additional
detail of progress,
for each student at the unit level,
including each student's mastery progress,
for that unit, and the class median,
for unit mastery progress.
Khan Academy also has a skills report,
found under the activity overview,
to dive deeper into the individual skills
for a given course.
On the skills report,
you can open any unit,
to get a quick view of how
students are progressing,
for the skills in that unit,
by looking at the purple
bars on the right side.
By clicking on a specific skill,
you will be able to see the mastery level,
for every student for that skill.
If you notice
that several students are
struggling on a skill,
you can assign extra
practice on that skill,
right here in the skills report.
We'll talk more about
how to make assignments,
in a separate video.
Some advice from teachers
using Khan Academy's course
mastery in their classrooms.
Mastering an entire course,
can feel daunting to students,
so break it up into
checkpoints, like monthly goals.
You can also consider
having students focus,
on particular units throughout the year.
Then check the unit report,
to see how they're doing.
Also you don't need to assign
the same course mastery
goal, to every student.
To differentiate, you can
assign different courses
to different students.
Some teachers even assign a mastery goal
for a previous grade level,
as review at the start of the year.
We hope this video helps you get started,
using course mastery with your students.